do the roasts yourself challenge please
can't wait for pity pies roast yourself
challenge felix where's the roast
yourself challenge you got called out by
keemstar i seriously what pity pie to do
the roasts yourself challenge roast
yourself challenge hey guys what's up so
ryan higa create a challenge called the
road rusev challenge where you yourself
[ __ ] why what up everyone it's your girl
Oh oh wow
this is already Oh worse mr. Neil
deGrasse Tyson please meme MFI my
feelings roast yourself challenge more
like cringe montage compilation I was
gonna make a joke that this video gave
me cancer but my channel is too big for
me to make those kind of jokes we really
need a challenge for you to admit your
past failures sounds pretty damn easy do
I even have to point out that the word
challenge is used just as a way to get
more views we should know by the way I
would never [ __ ] do I have integrity
this video gets a hundred thousand likes
I'll upload another challenge video you
think your fans eat up all that [ __ ]
whoa-hoo I'm not relevant as I used to
be boohoo my fans see me as this one
thing when I want to be another thing
you're all a bunch of crybabies know
what you're thinking yeah have I ever
pretended to be anything else how about
you all get some [ __ ] friends to
roast you you know like every [ __ ]
roast it's supposed to be the only
reason your friends don't roast you it's
because they hate you and it would be
too real excuse me while I hold my phone
just one line because remembering a
couple of lyrics it's clearly too
[ __ ] hard for my brain y'all feel bad
at roasting rose kid 1907 would [ __ ]
destroy you
hey I'm roasting the roast yourself
challenge you got it
you finally picked up on it huh the
video is pretty much the worst one out
of all of them I literally put no effort
in it where I try to be edgy and call
that all the other youtubers on their
[ __ ] even though I still do the same
[ __ ] thing well at least this video
will get more views
why am I not roasting myself because
everyone already knows that I'm pure
garbage but mainly because no matter
what the [ __ ] you say it'll be ain't
nothing's gonna make this face give a
[ __ ]
all right fine I'll do a diss track
can't be that hard stop rapping